Traduttore: Cecilia Secco
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Grazie.
Buongiorno a tutti.
Oggi ho il compito di parlare di tempo
in una logica di sostenibilità
e vi parlerò di sughero.
Vi parlerò di un qualcosa
che tutti noi conosciamo
ma probabilmente non lo conosciamo
sufficientemente,
per farvi un paragone su cosa vuol dire
il concetto di sviluppo sostenibile.
Il sughero esiste nel mondo
molto prima dell’uomo,
pensate che il sughero
è un patrimonio del Mediterraneo
e che è una quercia, una quercia
della famiglia della rovere
che ha sviluppato questa corteccia
per proteggerla dal fuoco
perché in questa zona del mondo,
milioni di anni fa, c'era il fuoco.
E questa corteccia fatta di aria
è talmente potente
che evita che l'albero bruci.
Perciò è un concetto di tempo millenario,
un concetto di tempo che si interfaccia
con la velocità dei giorni di oggi.
Pensate che il sughero
è un patrimonio del Mediterraneo
perché noi lo troviamo soprattutto
nel bacino occidentale del Mediterraneo,
lo troviamo nella penisola iberica,
tra cui anche il mio paese,
che è il principale produttore di sughero.
Perciò lo voglio contrapporre
ai tempi della velocità,
ai tempi del “tutto è veloce”,
perché se tu non fai le cose
hai perso l'attimo
e se tu hai perso l'attimo
quell'opportunità non ce l'avrai più.
Invece c'è un mondo, un mondo parallelo,
quello che io definisco un mondo “slow”,
dove chiaramente
la natura ha i suoi tempi.
Pensate che questo patrimonio
è uno dei 35 santuari
di biodiversità nel mondo.
Un albero di sughero per diventare
adulto ci mette ben 25 anni
e ogni 9 anni viene decorticato
come viene tosata una pecora.
Un tappo di sughero riesce
a diventare tappo dopo 45 anni,
perciò sono 250 anni di questo albero
che vegeta tra di noi.
È un albero estremamente sostenibile
perché aiuta a regolare
il ciclo idrogeologico,
previene la desertificazione
sociale e ambientale,
impiegando più di 100.000 persone,
è una materia rinnovabile e soprattutto
non si buttano giù gli alberi
per produrre i tappi di sughero.
Trattiene anche 112 grammi di CO2,
è una materia unica.
Pensate che in un centimetro cubo
di un tappo di sughero
ci sono 800 milioni di cellule.
Perciò un tappo di sughero,
che è il principale elemento
per chiudere una bottiglia di vino,
dona al vino eleganza, prestigio,
e un valore classico.
Perciò parliamo di un qualcosa
che ha a che vedere col tempo,
perché per noi il tempo è un valore
estremamente importante.
Un valore estremamente importante
perché essere sostenibile è un valore
estremamente importante,
perché la sostenibilità non va intesa
solo come sostenibilità ambientale,
la sostenibilità è un qualcosa
di più ampio.
D'accordo con la dichiarazione
delle Nazioni Unite del 1987,
per essere sostenibile
bisogna avere la capacità
di soddisfare i propri fabbisogni
senza compromettere i bisogni
delle generazioni future.
Pensate che noi, come esseri umani,
dobbiamo lasciare ai nostri figli
almeno il mondo che abbiamo
ereditato dai nostri genitori.
Perciò sviluppo sostenibile
non è solo ambiente.
Sviluppo sostenibile
è anche sviluppo economico,
sostenibilità economica
e anche sostenibilità sociale,
quella di cui io vi voglio parlare oggi.
Perciò qual è la sfida?
La sfida è come riuscire a
vendere slow nei tempi del fast.
Questa è la sfida
che io mi pongo tutti i giorni
con tutti i miei manager,
con tutti i miei collaboratori,
come riuscire a vendere slow
nei tempi del fast.
Perciò la cultura diventa fondamentale
perché è quella che riuscirà a
trasmettere
i valori della sostenibilità.
Solo attraverso la cultura,
la diffusione di questa cultura,
io riuscirò a inculcare nella testa
delle persone
che hanno a che fare con noi
quello che è il valore
di quello che io propongo.
Perciò il nostro primo target, chi sono?
Chiaramente voi, i consumatori.
Perciò il mio primo obiettivo
è quello di informare i consumatori.
I consumatori oggi stanno cambiando,
oggi la grande tendenza del consumo,
cioè il segmento che più interessa
a chi vende,
sono i millennials.
I millennials sono quelle persone
che sono diventate adulte
nel passaggio da un millennio,
perciò io credo la maggior parte di voi.
Allora, detto questo,
come ragiona il millennial?
Qual è il tipo di focus che lui cerca
nel momento in cui
deve acquistare qualcosa?
Lui cerca soprattutto le giuste cause.
Perciò è fondamentale che ogni prodotto
in qualche maniera incorpori
questa giusta causa.
Allora noi abbiamo deciso
di fare comunicazione
proprio di questa giusta causa nei tappi,
riuscire a dare a questi tappi
quello che è il valore intrinseco
dal punto di vista della sostenibilità,
in modo che chi stappa una bottiglia
capisca che quello ha un valore,
e quel valore è un valore
importante da difendere.
Questo diventa un aspetto
fondamentale per distinguerci
da tutta una serie di altri prodotti
che invece sono di matrice artificiale.
E dopo, i media:
saranno dieci anni che noi
gestiamo i rapporti con i media
e probabilmente siamo anche
una specie di case study
nel modo di rapportarsi con i media
perché i media diventano per noi
un veicolo fondamentale,
perciò parlo di televisione,
parlo di radio, parlo di carta stampata,
parlo di blogger, parlo di internet,
social network, tutti i media
diventano fondamentali per
diffondere questo messaggio.
Quando io porto un giornalista,
un blogger,
a toccare con mano questa materia,
loro si innamorano in un modo tale
che sentono anche proprio questo piacere
di difendere una causa giusta
e cominciano a vedere questo prodotto
con occhi completamente diversi.
Questo dopo si traduce
in quello che è la comunicazione,
quello che arriva dopo a ciascuno di voi,
perché è questo il nostro compito,
il compito di creare cultura.
E qual è il risultato?
Il risultato è chiaramente
che un giornalista o un cliente
che ha capito questa cosa
diventa un nostro ambasciatore,
perciò una persona che andrà
a diffondere questa cultura
e più cultura vuol dire
più valore aggiunto.
Tuttavia, solo questo non basta
perché questo è l'asse
della sostenibilità ambientale,
ma come vi ho detto sostenibilità
ambientale non è solo ambiente.
Sostenibilità è anche economia e sociale.
Quando parliamo di economia,
quando parliamo di risultati,
le aziende non esistono per caso,
le aziende esistono
perché ci sono le persone
e le persone diventano fondamentali,
cioè la tua squadra è fondamentale
per diffondere questo valore aggiunto,
per cercare di promuovere questo concetto.
Perciò il nostro ruolo è quello
di essere manager di talento.
Cioè, il concetto del “one man show”,
“io vi dico e voi obbedite”,
questo concetto oggi non funziona più.
Anzi, non credo che abbia mai funzionato.
Quello che oggi funziona è essere
in grado di gestire il talento,
perché le persone hanno
delle capacità enormi.
Bisogna andare a stuzzicare
questa capacità,
bisogna, attraverso quello che io
definisco
la “delega di responsabilità”,
riuscire a far capire a queste persone
che loro non sono un gatto,
loro sono un leone,
perché tutti noi abbiamo un leone
dentro di noi,
bisogna svegliare questo leone.
Allora noi siamo le leve del cambiamento,
cioè le cose non cambiano per decreto,
le cose cambiano perché noi
vogliamo che le cose cambino,
e per questo è imperativo che il manager
abbia la capacità di far uscire le persone
da quella che io definisco
la loro “zona di comfort”.
Devono andare fuori
da quella zona dove si addormentano
e invece mettersi in gioco costantemente.
E allora, come si fa questo?
Come si riesce a mettere in gioco
costantemente una persona?
Come si riesce ad allenare
un collaboratore?
Io parto da questo,
dal potential development analysis,
cioè l'analisi del potenziale di sviluppo.
Io vado a vedere attraverso un diagnostico
quelli che sono i potenziali,
come è costruito il terreno
di quella persona,
vado al di là di quello che può essere
un’intervista, un colloquio di lavoro,
perché quello non ti dice niente,
invece il potenziale ti dice
come è costruita questa persona,
qual è il suo profilo psico-attitudinale.
Ed ecco che il risultato si trasforma
in una specie di istogramma
che ti permette di capire esattamente
come è costruito questo terreno fertile.
Questo terreno fertile ha tre macro aree:
l'area del sentire, l'area dell'energia
e l'area della relazione.
Dalla correlazione tra queste aree
io riesco a individuare
come io posso effettivamente
seminare i frutti giusti
perché in questo terreno fertile
possa crescere qualcosa di importante,
sia per la persona sia per la mia azienda.
Perciò si tratta di capire
quali sono i muscoli da potenziare,
quali sono i muscoli invece
già perfettamente potenziati
e adatti a quelle che sono le sfide,
perché solo avendo il team giusto
si riescono a sfidare
anche le regole del mercato.
Anche la formazione diventa fondamentale
perché hai individuato le persone,
sai chi sono le persone che ti servono,
ma adesso devi formarle, e soprattutto
non solo i collaboratori
che tu hai in azienda ma anche
quelli che sono sul mercato,
quelli che devono passare il tuo valore.
Allora quello che noi cerchiamo
di fare e io cerco di fare
è far sviluppare il concetto
di essere imprenditore di te stesso.
Perché? Perché uno,
quando si sveglia alla mattina,
deve sapere cosa deve fare,
deve sapere dove deve andare,
deve sapere qual è il valore
che lui deve passare al mercato.
Allora io utilizzo da qualche tempo
questo modern business model canvas,
un modo molto semplice di insegnare
come fare un business plan,
come cercare in qualche maniera
di definire qual è il mio tragitto.
Ma non il mio tragitto
di questa settimana,
bisogna guardare almeno
uno spazio temporale di tre anni,
perché è nei tre anni che io riesco
chiaramente a cambiare qualcosa,
perché ogni giorno noi cambiamo
ma cambiamo solo un pezzettino.
L'altro aspetto fondamentale
è quello di sviluppare
il senso di appartenenza delle persone,
perciò la motivazione:
la motivazione di far parte del gruppo,
la motivazione di vestire
la maglietta dell'azienda,
e questo diventa fondamentale,
perché così tu avrai dei guerrieri
che combatteranno insieme a te
e così tu avrai capito
che solo insieme si vince.
Questa componente,
che io definisco
di sostenibilità economica,
permette effettivamente a tutti
i tuoi collaboratori di essere allineati
con quello che è il tuo progetto.
E per ultimo, la componente
della sostenibilità sociale.
Io sono convinto che essere
sostenibile vuol dire anche
essere capace di spendersi per gli altri,
cercare in qualche maniera
di aiutare il circondario,
aiutare il territorio
dove tu sei inserito.
Noi lo facciamo da anni
perché un'azienda si nutre
da un territorio
e questo territorio ti dà
i dipendenti, ti dà i fornitori,
ma tu al di là di questo,
al di là di pagare stipendi,
al di là di pagare le fatture,
anche tu devi lasciare qualcosa
in questo territorio,
perché effettivamente questo territorio
merita che tu lo aiuti.
Allora, nel 2011,
ho creato quello che è
il volto sociale della mia azienda:
si chiama Progetto Etico.
Voi direte, cos'è questo progetto etico?
Cos'è questa cosa?
Abbiamo deciso
di raccogliere i tappi usati.
Ognuno di voi sicuramente beve del vino,
poi siamo in Veneto,
perciò a maggior ragione,
e quando stappate la bottiglia
guardate questo tappo,
non sapete dove metterlo.
Allora abbiamo detto:
“Ma perché questo tappo
noi non lo recuperiamo
e andiamo a macinare questo tappo
trasformandolo in un materiale
di coibentazione?”.
Sapete che il sughero è il più grande
isolante naturale che esiste sulla Terra,
perché ricordatevi
che protegge l'albero dal fuoco.
Allora abbiamo iniziato questo progetto,
abbiamo raccolto più di 350 milioni
di tappi dal 2011 a oggi, in 6 anni.
Non sono tanti, considerato che oggi
vengono buttati nella spazzatura
circa 800 milioni di tappi all'anno,
ma noi siamo riusciti
a intercettare una piccola parte
e vi dico che abbiamo generato
un movimento grandioso
perché tutte le persone si domandavano
“Ma questi tappi, perché
non si possono recuperare?”
Abbiamo oggi più di 5.000
punti di raccolta
nel centro e nord Italia
e anche in poche parti del sud Italia.
Abbiamo più di mille volontari
che lavorano con noi
e che ci aiutano a recuperare i tappi.
Noi recuperiamo i tappi,
li trasportiamo con dei mezzi autorizzati,
li maciniamo e dopo li rivendiamo
ad aziende di bioedilizia.
E qual è il risultato
che noi siamo riusciti ad ottenere?
Prima di tutto, siamo riusciti a donare
più di 200.000 euro in beneficenza
e questo è già un traguardo importante
perché andiamo ad aiutare
tantissime delle 40 onlus
che lavorano con noi,
ma soprattutto siamo riusciti
a chiudere il cerchio.
Un cerchio iniziato nella foresta
con un movimento estremamente
sostenibile e rispettoso dell'ambiente,
passando per il modo con cui
noi ci approcciamo al mercato
fino a quello che è il fine vita
dei nostri prodotti.
Allora, cosa farei io con un'ora
in più
al giorno, o 40 minuti,
tanto non è rilevante?
Io cercherei di rendere
il mio passaggio per il pianeta Terra
il più sostenibile possibile
e probabilmente facendo così
io non avrei bisogno di andare
a cercare acqua su Marte.
Grazie